welcome to the 2009 MTV Movie Awards
covered by me and my cameras with
questions by you
first off let's get to the highlights I
met iCarly are you are icarly yes yeah
okay wait no I need to meet you I am
iJustine as you can clearly see I held
back and I only asked her one simple
question did you steal my name I swear
to you I swear to you oh nice - go -
yeah well if you think meeting icarly is
amazing let me tell you getting a
glimpse of three kids look exactly like
the Jonas Brothers is even better is the
Jonas Brothers I think it's the Jonas
Brothers
I'm not exactly the best at knowing who
all the celebrities are thankfully I had
a bunch of girls behind the hedges that
were helping me out and telling me who
everyone was
but when I did actually see someone that
I recognized guess what happened I am a
huge fan how are you my name is Justine
one I follow on Twitter what's your
Twitter I'm not involved
shut up there's work Hannah is the one
who walks around with a ever go like
that watch this is actually look exactly
twins after our wonderful Twitter
exchange
I asked Chet and Scott with their
favorite treats for my favorite cream
would have been buddy buddies I think it
was invented by the Mormons about 13
years ago
I'm easy I like scope trial of it takes
the rainbow there were plenty of times
when the people on the red carpet were
walking way too fast for me to ever be
able to interview so I resorted to
yelling 'yay like the poor Andy from the
office it's not really sure what
provoked me to do that but whatever I
also managed to get a few people to say
hi to you guys and here's dr. drew
saying what's up do you
and now here's drama from the fantasy
factory and nope I can't hear me there
but that's okay
just make up something that you want
them to say
so I'm not sure who this guy is but
there was a lot of yelling so I figured
we need to put him in here I also saw
Paris Hilton and after talking to a
bunch of reporters they actually said
the Paris Hilton is one of the nicest
people that they've ever met well if
that's the case let's hope their season
two BFF doesn't work out either because
season three hi IJ in Paris hey I'm not
sure if you guys remember when Sienna
Miller was hating on Pittsburgh a few
years ago well I asked her a little
credit Sienna passed by Whitney from the
hills also passed by looking very angry
more drama and your so-called reality
show somebody write you about scrubs
even if it is a bad script I'm probably
gonna watch it anyway admit it I'm not
the only one by watching everybody else
on the red carpet I was quickly learning
me get the celebrity's attention
technique and even once you've got that
technique down it doesn't always work
once the red carpet was over were
invited into the press tent to actually
watch the show all right here behind you
eat some bread this is actually the
Preston
now it was crazy because there are tons
and tons of press photographers
and I learned something you do not
whatever you do call a Press
photographer a paparazzi I made that
mistakenly got yelled at since I didn't
have the best of luck asking celebrities
questions on the red carpet I did
finally get to ask Chris Isaak two
questions so I knew a question that I
got off Twitter so they might be kind of
random I just added your questions
somebody wants to know what's your
favorite brand of string cheese I don't
think I have a favorite brand of string
cheese
I don't either this is a question wish
Zach Myers if you can't get the Zico
Myers I just don't eat string cheese
what kind of Jew face do you use your
bad questions cuz crazy what kind of
toothpaste I usually use whatever kind
of toothpaste
he's got laying around well thank you so
much you haven't led the MTV Awards
prevision sequence
oh and you heard it here first ben
stiller is in fact not on twitter fake
twitter or person not you amaze your
Witter
I don't know out there on Twitter are
you ever gonna not litigious so in here
second I don't know what a Twitter
there's a fake Twitter
speaking of Twitter Andy Samberg also
well I guess we'll never know his
thoughts on Twitter because I failed
either way he's an amazing job hosting
the award show what do you guys think
and last but not least the winner of
more Awards than probably everyone in
the entire show combined the guy who I
had no idea who he was prior to the
events becau hurry
that's all resolved now
wrong after the event I headed over to
their after-party and as most of you
guys know my dancing skills are known
existent thanks to Tom for his
encouragement and thanks to Scott for
the tips
that works
and of course the chat for setting a
very good dancing example also with the
after-party was a Kia car filled with
hamsters
thanks to you guys for watching and for
your excellent questions that you
submitted for me to ask the celebrities
for now leave me comments of questions
that you might want me to ask at future
events also huge thanks to nine home for
lighting into the event and if you
haven't already seen my 360 matrix style
video be sure to check that out you can
click right here or you can check it out
the cyber okay